Bonsoir!
M. Camara, entente avec la Ville
de Montréal, 347 000 $, après
avoir été accusé à tort d'avoir
agressé un policier,
au début de 2021.
On se rappelle de toute
l'histoire. Vous avez été accusé
d'avoir agressé un
policier. Aux dépens, la
poursuite initiale était de 1,2
millions. Êtes-vous satisfait de
cette entente?
- Merci de m'avoir invité. Le
ortant pour moi, c'est
essayé de tourner la page.
Retrouver ma santé et me
concentrer sur mes activités,
ail et ma famille. Comme
on le dit souvent, l'argent,
c'est jamais assez. L'essentiel
pour moi, c'est ma de de de de e
passer à autre chose.
- Comment vous allez
hui, monsieur camaras?
- J'ai eu beaucoup plus de
soutien de québécois, de ma
famille, de mes amis. J'essaie
de surmonter tout ça. Je vais
mieux aujourd'hui.
- Avez-vous senti
la population qui ne vous
connaît pas, mais qui voulait
vous envoyer des messages de
soutien?
- Tout à fait. Même en passant
par les réseaux sociaux, il y a
des gens qui me contactent, que
je ne connais même pas. Je
reçois des courriers de beaucoup
de personnes. Des personnes que
ais rencontrées. C'est
un soutien général de toute la
population. J'apprécie bien. Je
profite de votre antenne pour
leur dire merci pour le soutien
qu'ils ont apporté à moi et
famille durant toute
cette période.
- Ça a été traumatisant.
N'importe qui à votre place
aurait été sous le choc. Avez-
vous l'impression que vous
portez cette histoire tragique?
Avez-vous des images qui vous
habitent?
- Tout à fait. C'est quand même
difficile de se voir tout le
temps en ligne sur Internet.
Mais ce qui est important
aujourd'hui pour moi, c'est de
passer à autre chose, mais de
pousser les uns et les autres,
de prendre leurs responsabilités
pour ne pas que de telles
erreurs arrivent dans le futur.
Ce qui est très important.
- Avez-vous confiance envers les
policiers? Comment vous les
voyez aujourd'hui, les
policiers?
- Cette relation est quand même
difficile à rétablir. Mais je
pense, de leur côté, je peux
dire que c'est une
quand même. Et puis, ils vont
prendre des actions pour que
cela n'arrive pas. Je pense
qu'ils ont pris aussi des
engagements à ce que l'image de
la population puisse rétablir.
- Quand vous êtes au volant et
qu'il y a un autop
dans le secteur, êtes-vous
nerveux?
- Évidemment, que ce soit
Montréal ou un peu partout.
Lorsque je vois des voitures de
police, ça me fait revivre un
peu ce cauchemar. C'est
compliqué.
- C'est ça, vivre avec un
traumatisme, c'est long avant
d'en guérir. Est-ce que vous
avez espoir de retrouver une
confiance, de vraiment tourner
la page, même dans les
souvenirs, les réactions de
nervosité?
- C'est sûr que ça va être très
difficile, mais comme je vous ai
en
heureusement de plusieurs
personnes qui continuent de le
faire. Donc, je pense pouvoir
passer à travers tout ça et
retrouver la confiance.
- Ce qui a permis heureusement
de mettre fin à cette erreur
judiciaire et à vous sortir de
là, c'était des images d'une
caméra des transports. Si les
policiers avaient eu, à l'éoù v,
une caméra corporelle, ça aurait
changé l'histoire?
- Tout à fait. C'est pour ça que
des gens se sont levés pour
demander à ce que les policiers
et des caméras corporelles. Ça
aurait pu éviter cette erreur.
- Vous plaidez pour ces caméras
corporelles aujourd'hui?
- Vous étiez dans
maintenant, votre nom est
inconnu. Vous avez obtenu une
résidence permanente canadienne,
vous attendez la nationalité
canadienne. Vous
le père de deux jumeaux. Vous
êtes conscient de l'avenir?
- Je suis très confiant pour
l'avenir, avec les bébés. Je
sais que l'avenir me réserve
beaucoup de choses. Je compte
profiter pleinement avec les
jumeaux